[Musique]
je m'appelle Théo j'ai 24 ans depuis le
8 novembre dernier je doute tout le
temps sur mon âge je sais pas pourquoi
c'est un problème
premier sodo on a un bu on doit en
parler là
un peu moins ridicule de celui que
j'avais à l'époque non vraiment
dispo sur ma chaîne ou cacher un peu ok
je vous lance une exclure la première
apparition que j'ai faite sur Youtube
c'était sur la chaîne d'un pote qui
faisait du Call of Duty à l'époque il
devait avoir 14 ans on avait fait une
vidéo ensemble on entend que ma voix on
ne voit pas l'écran et la première vraie
apparition vidéo c'était en 2015 sur
airtone avec mon cousin aucun sens avec
ce que je fais aujourd'hui pareil
un sacré paquet de gens mais c'est trop
bien c'est incroyable et ça monte encore
ça s'arrête jamais
premier job j'en ai jamais parlé je
crois sur Youtube en plus c'était sur un
chantier en gros c'était l'usine du papa
d'un ami et du coup je travaillais sur
les chantiers avec des pioches des pets
et tout j'ai travaillé pendant un mois
j'ai arrêté parce que j'ai eu un labo et
après ça j'ai fait McDo et ensuite de
fil en aiguille
je vous laisse vétérinaires sauf que
j'ai fait mon bac S et j'ai eu deux en
maths du coup j'ai revu un peu mes plans
à la baisse du coup je partais sur
professeur de sciences de la vie de la
terre au lycée on a voulu voir du coup
ce que je fais aujourd'hui
c'est difficile comme question je me
souviens du moment où je me suis dit ça
y est ça décolle pour moi j'ai sorti une
vidéo en voiture dans laquelle en gros
je passais à côté d'une auto-école et je
m'étais des petites musiques de beauf et
il y a le moniteur d'auto-école qui a
commencé à danser avec moi et tout ça du
coup la vidéo a explosé c'est à ce
moment là où je me suis dit assez je
vais peut-être pouvoir en vivre mais le
moment vraiment je me suis dit j'ai
percé je crois c'est quand des gens que
je considérais comme étant des
célébrités des idoles venez vers moi
quand tu vois et je me disais mais
attends c'est possible et là je me
disais ouais bon j'ai mis un pied dans
une zone un peu inatteignable en temps
normal
ah ouais c'est la vie en voiture la
vidéo en voiture ou en gros il y a un
gars qui est soit en dehors de conduite
soit il passe le permis j'arrive à côté
lui en double file je mets une musique
de Patrice Bastien à fond et le moniteur
d'auto école qui commence à danser et
tout et le gars il est passé son permis
était comme ça c'est bon je l'ai c'est
passé c'était trop cool c'était un bon
moment
One Piece c'est un personnage fictif du
coup mais justement il est trop parfait
enfin je trouve que il véhicule plein de
valeurs trop stylées trop cool il donne
envie de se surpasser le fait même de
mettre lancé sur Youtube je pense que si
j'avais pas One Piece dans ma vie je
serai jamais lancé je me serais dit ah
non c'est trop compliqué comment on fait
pour percer sur un média pareille donc
ouais non je pense le film One Piece
non je crois pas des fois c'est plus
compliqué de trouver des idées que
d'autres comme j'essaie de lier ce qui
plaît aux gens et ce qui me plaît à moi
surtout c'est ça qui fait que c'est
compliqué mais vraiment en termes d'idée
sinon j'en ai toujours je pense sous la
main et puis maintenant je m'entoure
aussi de gens qui m'aident à trouver des
idées donc c'est plus simple non je
crois pas
je pense c'est d'être régulier on voit
le fait d'être régulier les gens
oublient pas tu t'améliores forcément
parce que du coup tu t'imposes un rythme
et tu essaies de toujours faire mieux
ouais je pense c'est ça être régulier
on peut se renouveler s'accrocher ouais
c'est innover le plus possible je pense
et tu vas bien c'est bien
passé une opportunité de dingue j'ai un
peu le syndrome de l'imposteur c'est je
vois des gens passer et tout je me dis
ouais ils ont fait des trucs de fou dans
leur vie et moi je suis là mais non en
vrai c'est cool c'est trop stylé j'étais
même pas venu à Cannes j'avais même pas
mis les pieds à Cannes c'est la première
fois vraiment et là dans quelques heures
je monte les marches pour la première
fois de ma vie un peu stressé et en même
temps je trouve ça kiffant j'ai hâte de
voir on va voir
je pense c'est un Disney Le Roi Lion
quand j'étais petit alors c'était
bizarre j'écoutais les cassettes en
boucle parce que j'adorais le Roi Lion
et du coup je dirais le Roi Lion film
d'animation mais je crois que toute ma
vie a été percée par les films
d'animation et sinon cinéma je fais très
peu original mais c'est Harry Potter
j'ai envie de dire c'est un film
d'animation incroyable allez voir
je pense que c'est bien que ça innove
donc c'est dans le respect dans le la
bonne humeur et tout je trouve c'est
cool en tout cas je me plains pas je
trouve ça cool et franchement j'ai
dérangé personne donc c'est le principal
non c'est vraiment bien je suis content
d'être là
j'ai envie d'être le personnage
principal d'un film mais il faut que
l'histoire me plaise j'aimerais trop un
film de super-héros je crois un peu
comme Tom landafé avec Spider-Man il a
eu la volonté de vraiment essayer de
faire une petite transformation physique
de se chauffer à faire des cascades et
tout je crois que j'aimerais trop me
surpasser et essayer de me donner comme
ça aussi
pense que la différence qu'il peut y
avoir entre par exemple YouTube et la
télé c'est que la télé est en place
depuis un long moment YouTube ça prend
forme petit à petit je sais que même moi
à titre personnel j'essaie de faire des
concepts de plus en plus gros du coup je
m'entoure d'équipe et tout ça je pense
que c'est cool de pouvoir faire des
connexions entre par exemple le monde du
cinéma et YouTube parce qu'à tout moment
ça peut déboucher sur des courses sur
des conversations super cool hyper hyper
enrichissante ils vont faire en sorte
que peut-être moi je vais me mettre à
produire un jour des trucs beaucoup plus
cool parce que je vais me dire ah ok lui
il a fait comme ça peut-être je peux
prendre un peu le même procédé donc je
trouve ça cool qu'il y a une connexion
entre les deux
j'ai perdu mon portefeuille mais
anecdote incroyable j'ai l'ai retrouvé
en fait c'est pas moi qui l'ai retrouvé
c'est une abonnée qui l'a retrouvé elle
a vu ma pièce d'identité elle m'a envoyé
un mail du coup c'est bon il n'est pas
perdu merci beaucoup pour de m'avoir
permis de participer à tout ça c'était
très cool et au plaisir